你想要什么？
如果你想要的是尊重这个东西啊，
除非你确实比男方要强很多，
能力上，
事业上，
见地上，
你能各种各样女都强过他，
他尊重你，
但是说普通老百姓之间，
夫妻之间，
你说男的一定尊重你吗？
这个半也很少见，
实话实说，
我老公家里是有一个店面两个工厂，
我公公婆婆是负责店面，
我和我老公是负责两个工厂的，
两个弟弟相差大概有200km左右，
我老公是两地跑，
收入大概一年就200多个，
但是钱都在我公公手里，
我自己私下里这几年存了50个放在我妈妈手上，
然后我家里都是农民工出生的，
然后爸妈都在老家打工，
我老公就是在怀孕期间的时候，
和我的员工就是搞在一块，
但是我爸妈为了照顾我坐月子，
都来我这边陪我，
我们是月底期间发现他们俩出去了似的，
闹得很大，
然家人闹得很不愉快，
就他家里面为了，
就权衡利弊吧，
从他赶走了，
最早的时候就一心一意的在，
在这个家嘛，
也没有那个心存钱，
一点钱都没有，
那个时候想连名，
但是一直连不上，
后来是看到里面很多那个切片，
有一个和我比较类似的，
当时您是建议他不要离，
然后就是建一给弄起来嘛，
我当时反正也是听进去了。
目前来说，
小孩现在四岁了，
手里弄了有50多个，
因为我公公把钱看得很紧，
以前都在我公公手上吧，
这几年我也只能弄这么多，
我老公现在这几年也没有，
就是在出现那种出车的情况了，
但我现在目前来说也不太信任他，
他手机反正也不给我看，
我们两个现在就是完全没有信任，
就是只有孩子吧，
他对孩子也挺好的，
孩子要啥他也给啥，
但是我觉得就是他们家一就把我当工人看了，
这两年就是我感觉我自己挺累的，
带孩子把你工厂自己一点时间都没有，
自由空间一点都没有，
这两年感觉自己压力比较大，
就是身体感觉就不像以前那么能干了嘛，
他和我们家基本上现在也没什么来往，
过年他也基本上不回我们家，
就我现在就是觉得不知道到底就是该不该，
你现在这个后面这个路我不知道该怎么走，
就是想让你给我一个建议，
就是或者是给我前面就是给一点指点，
这个事情啊，
就看自己过没过情关，
就是你对你的丈夫还有那种很爱很在乎，
她要是跟别人有点啥事儿的话，
你觉得痛彻心扉，
你觉得哎呀呼吸都呼吸不过来，
就看你还有没有那种状态，
如果说你对你的丈夫也没有那么强烈的爱，
也没有那么的在乎，
那这个时候我们就转变心态。
转变心态是什么呢？
我说句难听点的话啊，
如果咱们不是找了这样一个一年能挣200万的这样一个家庭的话，
是不可能在4年时间攒下来50万的私房钱的。
4年时间能攒下来50万的私房钱是什么概念呢？
就表示公公婆婆对你还不是像防贼一样防着，
还是比较大手大脚的，
比较大方的，
你才能攒下来50万的存款。
我们反过来讲，
假设我找的是一个一个月工资跟我差不多的三千五千的，
我俩在一起，
她也未必对我好，
她也未必尊重我，
她也未必对我专一，
而且我还攒不下来钱，
这是实话，
因为现实生活就是这样的，
我直播间应该有成千上万的女性现在过得就是这样的日子，
她找了一个不怎么挣钱的老公，
她照样不专一，
她照样不尊重我，
她照样对我娘家没有什么好脸色，
照样是，
我在带孩子照样是，
而且区别在于什么？
我还攒不下来钱，
我甚至还欠债，
我甚至还要去填他的窟窿。
所以这事儿的话，
就看你怎么想这个问题，
就像你想要什么，
如果你想要的是尊重这个东西啊，
除非你确实比男方要强很多，
能力上，
事业上，
见地上，
你能各种各样女都强过他，
他尊重你，
但是说普通老百姓之间，
夫妻间，
你说男的一定尊重你吗？
这个专业很少见，
实话实说，
我公公婆婆还好一点，
我感觉我老公就是很瞧不起我家。
那这个事情就看有的时候我们从历史剧里面去找答案了，
你要想象一下，
你想成为像芈月呀，
孝庄啊，
或者说那个窦太后啊，
想成为那样的角色吗？
想成为那样的角色的话，
就得身体健康，
活得长，
就得看得开，
就得该吃吃该喝喝，
该干嘛干嘛。
她今天此时此刻瞧不上我，
是因为我确实没有什么让她瞧得起的东西。
女人啊，
不是说我给你家生了孩子，
你就一定瞧得起我，
我确实没有什么让你能瞧得起我的东西。
第一，
我不像其他的说那个销售冠军一样，
可以给你拉来新的客户，
第二，
我不像那些公关的能力很强的人一样，
可以去跟你公关，
政府关系，
官员关系，
第三，
我也没有办法说在这个业务方向上给到我的公公婆婆和我的老公一个业务指引，
说这个业务不行了啊，
我学习了一个AI的业务，
我们全面转型做AI，
我们能够一年干400万，
我做不到那样的对他们有价值，
有推动，
所以他们不尊重我才是常态，
我这个可以做成贴片吗？
因为我想后面就有姐妹们评论或者什么的，
我自己可以在底下多反复的看，
可以没问题啊，
所以这个事情的话，
从你目前的现状来看，
只要说你不是对这个男人还爱的死去活来没有的话，
那咱就是真的一门心思的攒钱，
一门心思的搞好自。
的身体，
让自己活得长，
一定要就每天要想想，
我跟谁在一起是快乐的，
我就多跟谁在一起，
如果说我跟公公婆婆在一起不快乐，
我就少见面，
但是我也不去伤他们的情分，
他们给我钱，
给我生活费，
我都要表达感恩。
没事儿感恩节的时候给公公发条短信，
要感谢他，
没事父亲节的时候给公公发条短信，
要感恩他。
没事儿要教育自己的孩子，
无论是儿子还是女儿，
一定要对强者有抱大腿的这样一个思想，
因为人的感情是很玄妙的，
他一旦有一天说公公生病吗？
小孙女儿给他端茶倒水的心疼他，
摸摸他的胡子，
摸摸他的手，
一下子什么财产都想给小孙女儿，
其他的都是扯淡，
亲情才是王道，
我没骗你们啊，
人有的时候感情就是这么脆弱，
比如说他有一天他摔了，
哎呀，
这小孙女儿不顾一切的跑过去要扶她起来，
那一瞬间他就想，
哎呀，
我的财产，
我要给我孙女置办房产，
我要给我孙女儿置办嫁妆，
我要让我孙女儿一辈子衣食无忧，
没有人敢去负我公公和我婆婆，
他们现在想让我生二胎，
但是我没有这个意愿呀，
你就算没有这个意愿，
你也不能卡死，
我跟你说，
嗯，
你也得答应，
口头上也得答应，
但是这个事儿由你自己决定，
是不是好了好，
就这样啊，
啊，
大家刚才那个姐妹啊，
就是一旦你想通了之后可以生，
为啥我？
跟孩子出来一句，
我也不图说老公尊重我，
我也不图公公婆婆尊重我，
我图的是我的孩子有好的起点，
我的孩子能过得比我好，
我的孩子能比我接受更好的教育，
比我站在更好的人生起点上。
记得点赞关注哦。